nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
direction les États-Unis pour parler des
migrants venus d'Afrique les Africains
représentent 5% des immigrés aux
États-Unis mais leur population est
celles qui croient le plus chaque année
pour beaucoup l'Amérique et la terre de
tous les possibles mais la réalité
s'avère parfois plus difficile Fanny
Allard correspondante de France 24 aux
États-Unis est avec nous c'est ce qu'on
va découvrir dans votre reportage et
parmi les difficultés auxquelles se
heurtent les Africains il y a une forme
de racisme à leur égard de la communauté
afro-américaine qu'on a du mal à
imaginer pourtant de prime abord
je ne sais pas si on peut vraiment
parler de racisme mais ce qui est
certain c'est que la relation entre
Africains et afro-américain est complexe
et souvent faite de stéréotypes en fait
dans une certaine mesure les
Afro-Américains en vie les Africains de
savoir qui ils sont édou ils viennent
parce que que ce soit du Cameroun du
Niger du Bénin ou de Côte d'Ivoire ces
africains viennent tous d'un pays avec
une culture propre or les
Afro-Américains sont des Américains et
non d'Africains que l'ascendance
lointaine
hérité de l'esclavage et c'est bien là
tout le problème ils sont issus d'une
immigration forcée ont subi des
discriminations depuis 400 ans en
subissent encore aujourd'hui et ils
portent la nationalité d'un pays qui
peine encore parfois à assumer son
histoire il y a donc je dirais comme un
complexe d'identité mais l'erreur je
crois est de penser qu'Africains et
afro-américains auraient plus en commun
tout simplement parce qu'il partage la
même couleur de peau alors on va
découvrir votre reportage Fanny on vous
retrouve juste après reportage signé
Fanny à l'art pour France 24
[Musique]
puisque c'est tellement différent de mon
pays je me suis dit bon pourquoi pas
essayons voir s'il y a une meilleure vie
de l'autre côté un avenir meilleur c'est
ce qui est venu chercher Aurore aux
États-Unis cette béninoise de 47 ans est
chauffeur de Hubert à Washington un
métier qu'elle n'aurait jamais imaginé
exercée je crois que mon père de Satan
doit être en train de se remuer pourquoi
j'ai payé toute cette scolarité
si c'est pour finir chauffeur de taxis
je n'avais rien je n'avais aucune
connaissance de l'anglais avant
d'immigrer au Bénin Aurore était cadre
dans une entreprise de communication ici
elle roule 12 à 14h par jour et prend en
moyenne 25 passagers entre la Virginie
le Maryland et Washington
ce jour là elle dépose des clientes près
du Capitole des États-Unis
à l'évé
selon les mois et les heures travaillées
Aurore gagne mis la 1500 dollars par
semaine un salaire conséquent mais qui
aux États-Unis suffit péniblement à
couvrir ses charges elle n'arrive pas à
épargner et doit parfois demander à sa
mère de lui envoyer de l'argent depuis
le Bénin c'est beaucoup d'argent mais
compte tenu du coup de la vie ici c'est
ça c'est rien
il faut déjà payer le loyer à 2000
dollars vous imaginez 2000 dollars c'est
un million de francs Cfa c'est un palace
chez moi au Bénin quand on est en
Afrique on pense que les États-Unis
c'est l'Eldorado et
ce n'est pas tout à fait ça
un désenchantements que ne partage pas
tous les immigrés africains aux
États-Unis chaque année des milliers de
subsahariens et de nord africains
tentent leur chance de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique
[Musique]
il est né à Bizerte sur les rives de la
Méditerranée mais avant de quatre ans il
a décidé que l'avenir serait en Amérique
aujourd'hui il y a 48 ans il est le
manager du prestigieux George Town club
c'est comme un bateau là c'est comme le
Titanic un endroit privé réservé aux
membres où il s'occupe aussi de choisir
les vins
c'est auprès d'une marocaine qu'il fait
sa sélection vous êtes au rabat non non
pour avoir mon tajine le pôle
j'ai commencé comme un serveur à elle le
sens et après j'ai venu ici j'ai
commencé
Washington pour sa proximité avec le
nord de l'Afrique
mais aussi pour sa diversité car dans la
capitale américaine et ses environs on
trouve plus de 170 nationalités c'est
mon choix de
d'être vraiment un Américain parce que
l'Amérique elle m'a donné tout pourquoi
pas je donne aussi
c'est vrai c'est ça c'est mentalité et
comment elle l'a dit le président
Kennedy donne ask a merry
what you can do for américain
un choix de vie qu'il n'a jamais
regretté en Tunisie après la Révolution
plusieurs de ses amis d'enfance sont
partis faire le jihad deux copains ou un
voisin de Bizerte qu'il est parti en
Syrie il est mort là-bas il y en a notre
de Marseille
en tunisien sa mère française
il a laissé sa femme
enceinte elle est partie en série bye
bye
il est mort
j'ai rien à faire en Tunisie
ma vie c'est ici c'est comme on dit le
dernier transit de ma vie parmi les
immigrants africains environ 20 000
arrivent chaque année grâce à la loterie
de la carte verte un système instauré
par Ronald Reagan dans les années 80 et
qui permet au gagnant de venir vivre et
travailler aux états-unis
Edwin et camerounais anglophone il est
arrivé il y a 5 ans grâce à cette
loterie quand je suis arrivé ici je me
suis dit c'est le début d'une nouvelle
aventure pour être éligible à la loterie
il faut avoir le bac et être né dans un
pays avec un faible taux d'immigration
aux États-Unis Edwin a été sélectionné
après quatre tentatives
j'ai préparé tous les documents
nécessaires et parmi les conditions
requises il fallait faire des tests
médicaux ensuite j'ai eu un entretien à
Yaoundé à l'ambassade américaine que
j'ai réussi
ils m'ont félicité et ils m'ont dit
bienvenue aux États-Unis
le jeune homme vient d'obtenir son
diplôme d'ingénieur informatique à
l'Université du Maryland le début de
tous les possibles
je suis très fier de ce que j'ai
accompli jusqu'à présent et ce sont les
États-Unis qui ont rendu cela possible
ils m'ont donné une chance je l'ai saisi
et je suis infiniment reconnaissant
[Musique]
nous retrouvons Aurore la béninoise dans
une zone commerciale de Silver Spring
elle s'offre exceptionnellement quelques
heures de bien-être en allant se faire
tresser les cheveux dans le salon d'une
amie
comment tu vas comment va la famille ce
matin
ça va
les deux femmes se sont connues il y a 7
ans à l'arrivée d'Aurore aux États-Unis
elle travaillait alors ensemble dans le
même salon de coiffure
une amitié facilitée par un langage et
des racines communes Liliane vient-elle
aussi d'Afrique de l'Ouest c'est vrai
que c'est un continent mais c'est un
pays surtout l'Afrique francophone on a
pratiquement les mêmes cultures on se
comprend on mange pratiquement les mêmes
repas on réfléchit de la même manière on
a les mêmes réalités
ce qui n'est pas pareil avec une
afro-américaine par exemple les
relations entre Africains et
afro-américains sont souvent compliqués
en 7 ans aux États-Unis Aurore nié
aucune amitié avec l'un d'entre eux
parfois elles pensent que le aïeux ont
été vendus par les nôtres donc il y a
cette jalousie il y a cette jalousie du
fait que nous quand on vient ici on sait
pourquoi on est venu on se cherche on se
bat et ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
de leur côté pendant longtemps il faut
seulement essayer de connaître ta place
et saisir les choses
le jugement d'Aurore est plus sévère
fouille de ces rencontres et expériences
passées c'est des gens qui vont
peut-être t'approcher et puis bon ben le
lendemain tu reconnais plus la même
personne pour eux l'amitié c'est quelque
chose de de superficiel c'est et par
contre pour l'africaine que je suis
l'amitié sacrée
[Musique]
s'intégrer dans une société et en
épouser ses codes demande de la
résilience c'est ce cadenas le Tunisien
a réussi à faire il est marié depuis 22
ans à Rachel une Américaine de Virginie
qui la rencontrée ici sa famille fait
partie de l'accomplissement de son rêve
américain
elle m'a donné la liberté la joie et
tout
c'est ça m'a donné une famille j'ai pas
imaginé que je veux voir un blanc avec
moi pour le moment
c'était mon rêve aussi avoir une blonde
le français d'Anna n'est parfois
hésitant après 24 ans aux États-Unis le
Tunisien serait-il devenu complètement
américain oui mais pas seulement je
crois qu'il a gardé un peu ces valeurs
tunisiennes surtout
comment il me guide un peu j'ai pas
complément reçu
il est un peu plus droite les États-Unis
ont été fondés par des immigrants la
famille de Rachel par exemple est venue
d'Allemagne au début du 20e siècle pour
poursuivre une vie meilleure éternelle
promesse de l'Amérique
nous avons construit une vie prospère
dans ce pays c'est le résultat d'un
melting pot d'un mélange des gens donc
oui je continue à vivre le rêve
américain
ce rêve Edwin le Camerounais veut aussi
le faire sien ce soir là il fait route
vers la Virginie je ne peux pas dire que
le système soit parfait ici
mais dans une certaine mesure le système
est plus favorable qu'au Cameroun plus
égalitaire
en attendant de trouver un emploi qui
correspond à son niveau d'études le
jeune homme est DJ dans des événements
une activité qu'il affectionne
particulièrement
je vais jouer ma que ça love c'est de la
musique camerounaise des rythmafros et
aussi de la musique sud-africaine
aux États-Unis Edwin a pu s'offrir la
platine de ses rêves
c'est mon nouveau bébé je l'appelle mon
bébé parce que j'adore ce truc
[Musique]
le jeune homme n'est pas retourné au
Cameroun depuis son arrivée il y a 5 ans
un exil parfois difficile mais qui
l'assume tout ce que je veux accomplir
je peux le faire ici alors oui ça vaut
largement la peine
même si ma famille mes amis est la
nourriture
[Musique]
mais le mal du pays ne touche pas tous
les Africains de la même manière
si Aurore tient bon c'est uniquement
pour sa fille Sacha scolarisée aux
États-Unis depuis ses 5 ans
mis
aurore est d'abord arrivée avec un visa
touriste elle pensait ne restait aux
États-Unis que quelques mois il essaie
sa fille mais sa situation personnelle a
changé c'est quoi les bonnes nouvelles
de l'autre côté
je m'accroche comme d'habitude à la
maison elle prépare la cuisine avec des
épices du pays
ma nourriture africaine je ne m'en
sépare pas un amour profond du Bénin
Correur transmettent à sa fille à cheval
entre deux cultures moi je sens
africaine quand je suis avec mes
familles mais quand je suis à l'école et
avec mes amis je sens Amérique
Sacha espère intégrer l'université de
Yelle après le lycée et parachever le
rêve américain que lui offre sa mère non
sans sacrifice le vrai américain est
possible quand on y vient jeune mais
pour 90% de ceux qui ont immigré vers
les États-Unis le rêve américain c'est
juste illusoire
illusion ou réalité une chose est
certaine pour aimer l'Amérique il ne
faut pas seulement l'avoir rêvée il faut
être prêt à s'y fondre sans compter
[Musique]
et on retrouve Fanny Allard notre
correspondant aux États-Unis qui a
réalisé ce reportage Fanny beaucoup
d'immigrés arrivent dans le pays grâce
un système de loterie pouvez-vous nous
expliquer ce fonctionnement qui nous
paraît un peu étrange ici vu de France
alors la loterie de la carte verte cette
balle en réalité le diversité visa
loterie c'est un visa diversité il est
distribué chaque année à 55000 personnes
issues des pays éligibles parmi ces pays
ont trouvé évidemment des pays africains
mais aussi des pays d'Asie des pays du
Moyen-Orient et des pays d'Europe il y a
moins de pays d'Amérique du Sud parce
qu'il faut être citoyen d'un pays dont
le taux d'immigration aux États-Unis est
faible il y a de nombreux participants
pour peu d'élus l'année dernière par
exemple il y avait 7 millions de
candidats la participation est gratuite
elle se fait en ligne il faut avoir au
moins deux ans d'expérience
professionnelle ou le bac et un
passeport valide mais une fois
sélectionné ça ne veut pas dire que vous
obtenez cette carte verte il faut
ensuite remplir plusieurs documents
administratifs et se rendre à un
entretien c'est complètement aléatoire
mais si l'on gagne comme Edwin qu'on a
vu dans le reportage et bien ce visa
donne accès à la carte qui est un
véritable passeport pour les États-Unis
il permet d'étudier de vivre et de
travailler aux états-unis il permet
également de faire venir sa famille son
conjoint ou ses enfants au nom du
regroupement familial et puis au bout de
5 ans vous pouvez demander la
nationalité américaine pour les
États-Unis c'est un moyen efficace de
choisir et de contrôler son immigration
finalement oui cette fameuse Green Card
alors pourquoi est-ce que les Africains
francophones que vous avez rencontrés
n'ont pas choisi la France plutôt que
les États-Unis bien tout simplement
parce qu'il n'y a pas en France
d'équivalent à cette loterie de la carte
verte nous n'avons pas de programme qui
offre autant d'avantages et puis il y a
aussi deux réalités d'une part la
relation post-coloniale parfois ambigu
avec la France qu'on les Africains et
puis d'autre part le fait que les
États-Unis exerce encore à travers le
monde une vraie fascination cela reste
dans l'imaginaire collectif le pays de
tous les possibles et dans une certaine
mesure c'est vrai et ça l'est d'autant
plus pour les enfants d'immigrés on
parlait tout à l'heure de la relation
compliquée entre Africains et
afro-américain mais c'est différent
c'estompe en une génération Aurore la
béninoise que vous avez vu dans le
reportage me disait assez justement que
l'on est du pays où l'on est et où on
grandit elle est bien que ce ne soit pas
vrai évidemment dans tous les cas je
pense que c'est peut-être ça la
conclusion Fanny Allard correspondante
de France 24 aux États-Unis merci Fanny
c'est la fin de ce magazine merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
reporter
[Musique]